six girls from Afghanistan are in the
u.s. this morning to compete in the
International robotic Olympics it
follows an extraordinary journey from
their war ravaged country to Washington
supporters gathered at the airport to
greet the team when they arrived this
weekend chip Reid in Washington shows us
how the girls overcame numerous
challenges chip good morning
well good morning you can see behind me
kids on the steps of Constitution Hall
waiting to go inside for this
competition you know in Afghanistan it
can be dangerous to even pursue an
education for girls and these girls were
told as recently as last week that this
trip would be impossible more than 50
supporters mostly strangers showered the
girls with flowers and hugs when they
arrived Friday night competitor samaya
Ferrucci was overjoyed she told us quote
I want to thank everyone who greeted us
welcomed us and didn't forget us
the team has faced adversity from the
beginning they were supposed to receive
a box of building materials from the US
months ago but terrorism concerns
blocked the shipments arrival so the
girls scraped together the materials
themselves and built their roba in just
two weeks then the girls traveled 500
miles to the Embassy in Kabul to get
their visas twice they were denied both
times they were devastated but last week
President Trump authorized the visas the
girls needed to travel to America they
were deeply grateful that they and
Afghanistan were not forgotten team
Afghanistan
now the girls will compete for a medal
against a hundred and sixty two other
teams Afghan ambassador hamdullah Moe
[ __ ] says the Afghan people will be
watching seeing them in seeing the
talent that they represent gives us the
hope that Afghanistan has the potential
to become a stable and prosperous
country it's still unclear why the girls
visas were initially refused the State
Department says they can't even discuss
it because of privacy concerns and by
the way Afghanistan is not one of the
six nations included in the president's
travel ban but five of those nations are
represented here they are Syria Iran
Libya Yemen and Sudan pretty amazing not
amazing indeed these girls continue to
find the odds who wish them all well
chip thank you